la sphère mesrine
après son agression contre jacques
tillier et de notre confort de
l'hebdomadaire minute
mesrine a écrit hier à plusieurs de nos
confrères de la presse écrite un résumer
disons que jacques mesrine affirme
n'avoir pas voulu tuer tillier mais
avoir voulu le pu lire par ailleurs
selon certains la police estimait que
jacques tillier n'a pas donné une
version tout à fait exact disons de ce
qui s'est passé réellement lundi matin
je vais essayer de rejoindre ma place
sans trop de problème voilà c'est fait
une version tout à fait exact de ce qui
s'est passé lundi matin alors
aujourd'hui on peut quand même se poser
une question où est la vérité
et bien pour la première fois la vérité
nous allons peut-être la connaître au
moins une des vérités de cette affaire
car jean jacques dufour pour la première
fois jacques tillier sur son lit
d'hôpital à accepter ce matin de
répondre aux questions d'un journaliste
de télévision devant des caméras de
télévision alors j'ai rencontré tout à
l'heure dans le couloir de l'hôpital
juste avant de m'entretenir avec jacques
tillier la demoiselle balestra zee qui
est commissaire au srpj de creil
elle m'a affirmé nous n'avons jamais dit
que nous mettions en doute la version
des faits donnée par jacques tillier
donc non démenties 7 1 des ventes de ces
informations qui disait que jacqueline
n'aurait peut-être pas dit toute la
vérité ce qui revêt pas d'impacts de
balles dans la cuisse à cyril fausses
informations censées se démentit corps
directement ce matin dans le couloir de
l'hôpital voilà pour ce point mais
revenons-en à la lettre de mesrine ou
plus exactement au lait ou l'envoyer le
lancaster au matin de paris à l'aurore
au quotidien libération bien minutes et
amis aux substances
on peut y lire truc là je prends mon
papier parce que il faut que je regarde
une citation trion d'honneur ça n'existe
pas mais l'honneur bafoué
ça se défend jusqu'au meurtre jusqu'à
l'absurde jusqu'à l'odieux dans la
violence
le ton est donné ensuite le gangster
explique qu'il n'a pas voulu tuer
tillier mais le corriger je n'aime pas
les gens qui salissent pour le plaisir
il accuse ensuite le journaliste de lui
avoir proposé quatre cent mille francs
pour cette interview et d'avoir voulu
lui tendre un piège
il explique aussi qu'il a enregistré à
son insu le journaliste et que celui ci
a sali c'est en tout cas le mot
qu'emploie mesrine lé commissaire
broussard et devos mesrine n'apprécie
pas ils préfèrent des adversaires comme
eux injac t-il à propos de cet
enregistrement jacques mesrine a dit
qu'il le communiquera ultérieurement
mesrine s'en prend aussi à
l'hebdomadaire minute et à son de sa
direction et de conclure je n'ai pas à
être en glorifier je suis un criminel
mais je n'ai pas à être sali injustement
à dater de ce jour ce sera le tarif de
la key lors l'homme ça c'est donc la
version jacques mesrine c'est l'une des
vérités de cette affaire l'autre vérité
c'est celle que vous avez recueillis
c'est ça de nous engage à qui nous avons
pu voir jacques tillier très fatigué
deux balles n'ont pas encore été
extraite
il a pourtant accepté de répondre à nos
questions et à la lettre de jacques
mesrine lettre dans laquelle le gangster
affirme donc qu'il n'a pas voulu tuer le
journaliste demi
écoutons donc cette interview de jacques
tillier je pense que il se dit très fort
il n'est peut-être plus fort que le
médecin légiste qui prouve le contraire
comme moi je sais bien ce qui s'est
passé dans la droite et si mesrine ne
voulais pas me tuer il suffisait tout
simplement que devant le chemin en
matière de balles dans les jambes ou
comme empêché d'écrire une balle dans la
balle dans la main pendant péché
d'écouter une balle dans le rail il me
laissait avec mais honnêtement me
regarde pas rester immobile côté
téléphone à la main d'un mari à me
retrouver comme ça il n'y a pas de
problème la hume qui naissent dans un
trou noir
attachés avec une ceinture et enfin les
pieds un pas les mains attachés avec une
ceinture avec quand même une balle qui
reste la mine ici une île et peut-être
vexé parce que mal ok mais c'est pas mon
problème
tant que je suis moi je suis très
content qu'ils mélo mais il dit aussi
que vous avez voulu le piéger et voliez
lui tendre un piège
ouais je sais pas si je voulais le pied
enfin depuis le départ c'est quand même
lui qui va payer
derrière il est persuadé jacques mesrine
c'est quand même un grand garçon et elle
avait eu des rendez vous secrets
c'est pas juste pas le premier
deuxièmement il ya car l'interview comme
ça va très bien et serait né s'appelle
non seulement me serais ne peut le dire
mais et ça on en parlera un jour où
peut-être que les intermédiaires en
parlerons jour tout seul
jacques mesrine savait très bien qu'il
n'y avait pas de policiers derrière que
les policiers et a suivi par les
policiers qu'il n'y avait pas de
policiers que les policiers n'étaient
pas prévenus de cette interview que je
n'était porteur d'un baby ben je peux
même vous dire mieux jacques mesrine
était tellement confiant que il m'a
fouillé uniquement en masse on m'a
fouillé uniquement dans la voiture le
haut mais j'aurais très bien pu avoir si
j'avais été un homme de la police
j'aimerais bien y avoir un bip bip dans
mon sac
il a jamais fouillé mon sac ou sur mes
jambes j'aurais pu avoir un pistolet je
me suis trouvé tout seul un mois il y
avait jacques mesrine devant moi dans la
grotte
parce que faut rentrer dans la grotte à
jacques mesrine
quand on est journaliste à minute
sachant les opinions politiques les
jacques mesrine
jacques mesrine était devant moi avec
son ami paul moi j'étais derrière il y
avait uniquement un milliard de de brick
& click et qui nous éclairait j'aurais
très bien pu avoir un pistolet à eau que
j'ai ressorti de monts
de ma cuisse et les abattre tous les
deux mesrine avec confiance en moins
d'ailleurs il le dit dans la lettre
savaient très bien qui peut rien se
passer du tout vous avez été policier à
la dst est ce que vous pouvez penser
qu'à cause de salades mesrine a pu
laisser croire que vous aviez encore des
relations avec deux anciens abonnés donc
c'est pas ça que jacques mesrine a voulu
punir une journaliste de minute quelques
monstres inve jouer aux brigades rouges
ça c'est son problème ce n'est pas le
maire jacques mesrine a voulu punir un
journaliste de minute punir un ancien
flic moi d'être d'avoir été ancien
ancien policier non seulement j'en suis
vraiment fier mais absolument rien à
rougir
en ce qui concerne l'enregistrement que
mesrine a fait la preuve c'est bien la
preuve que c'est lui qui est un piège
s'il est malade moi aussi et
l'enregistrement que mesrine a fait je
suis alors vraiment très serein chacun
sait aussi bien du côté de mon journal
que l'information policière c'est à dire
les policiers ce que j'ai dit ce que
j'ai pas dit ce que j'aurais pu dire
savez c'est plus on m'a dit hier
quelqu'un m'a téléphoné hier par me dire
que les gendarmes avaient fait la
reconstitution et j'ai rien contre les
gendarmes
mais comme j'en avais mis dix minutes du
fond de la grotte fameux beau secouer me
suis caché gendarmes avaient des bons
brodequins si une cigarette au bec
moi j'étais à pau elle trois balles dans
le corps la trouille pilotes reviennent
des quatre cent mille francs questions
que vous auriez offert à jean grey
screen pour cette année ça c'est à mon
directeur qu'il faut poser la question
si on veut bien donner 40 millions je
prends tout de suite
pensez vous qu'ils avaient pris contact
avec mesrine et c'est bien c'est lui qui
vous a joint ecoutez-moi al'inverse de
mesrine tu jamais balancé personne dans
ma vie il ya ce que mesrine appel dans
sa lettre ces faux amis
ils seront ravi de l'entendre et ça je
crois que c'est assez faux amis de
parler peut-être qu'ils parleront le
jour et vous avez réussi à le retrouver
comment ça c'est mon problème mais je
l'expliqué dans minute et déjà plus un
parti garant pour moi comme il ya des
gens qui sont portés garants pour
mesrine vis-à-vis de moi ces gens là ont
été trompés ces gens là sont des voyous
ces gens-là soins code
quoi qu'on dise mesrine et peut-être que
ce sera un jour quelque chose de le dire
[Musique]